all right so big turnout today obviously
you know nevada's battleground state
very important for any campaign
so i guess how important is nevada to
the president's campaign and
what are you guys doing specifically to
you know covet the nevada vote and the
minority vote specifically the hispanic
film well the hispanic vote sort of a
no-brainer actually did a sort of a
great trip this weekend in florida with
jorge masvadal the great ufc fighter
you know talking about the perils of
socialism and communism and since that's
become such a mainstay
now of the democrat party that's pretty
scary but the reality
for for the hispanic vote it's about
jobs donald trump created the greatest
job market america has ever known the
economy he created the strongest economy
we've ever seen
you know he's fighting for americans
he's making sure that americans have
that opportunity donald trump
renegotiated the failed trade deals that
joe biden pushed for 50 years
to benefit american workers he took on
china
he's getting us out of the endless wars
that's not just for nevada that's
awesome that's just awesome for the
world but certainly all americans and
more importantly he's getting peace
deals done in the middle east
you know so donald trump is tackling
those things he's not a politician like
joe biden who's been there for 47 years
and i would bet that your average
listener or viewer
couldn't name a single accomplishment of
his but now he wants to do it now he's
going to fix it
you know donald trump is the guy that
fixed what some of the stuff that joe
biden says he's going to fix racial
injustice in america donald trump did
the first step act
and prison reform and opportunity zones
those weren't republican things to do
they were just the right thing to do
donald trump tackled them joe biden
talks about wanting to do things but
why hasn't he done them already why
didn't he utilize his time as
a senator for 38 years or as the vice
president for eight years to do those
things
because he's all talk donald trump
delivers results and i think people
respect that and understand it
so obviously uh mr president has just
recovered from
kobit 19 and he's been very vocal about
it everyone's so glad he's okay
um how you know not everyone not
everyone
not if you've been looking at social
media how how has you know this changed
his view on the virus and
you know how to handle the pandemic and
how he moves forward i think it's
it's very much the same strategy which
is i mean you can take reasonable
precaution he took they took extreme
precautions i mean anyone who goes
around him
has to be tested on a daily basis
literally uh
and he was still able to get it but he
was also you know he's a 74 year old guy
that probably eats a little too much
mcdonald's and
he walked out in two days so i think you
can take it seriously you can take
reasonable precautions if you're elderly
or if you have pre-existing conditions
take it more seriously
but i think you can strike a happy
medium between being responsible
without destroying your life without
destroying your business your livelihood
uh you know if joe biden did just lock
it up there could be one case somewhere
in guam and they'll lock down the whole
country
that's not a good approach i would
destroy businesses that would do more
damage to people whether it's depression
whether it's losing your home
suicide rates uh from not having any
income and losing your family and
breaking out and that would do more
damage than the virus could ever do so
what we've tried to do and what we've
done very well in a lot of the
republican states with governors who you
believe in those things is
you're coming up with a happy medium
where you can live your life while being
responsible and that's what he would do
um talk about maryland voting obviously
a big point of contention specifically
here in nevada and you know with
different attempts to
to block that process um the mail-in
voting expansion across the state
how does the campaign feel about it now
moving forward um since you know that
there are very low levels of fraud
well who says who have you been looking
around the country because it doesn't
seem that low when they find
you know what was it 27 000 ballots the
other day magically
all incorrect it's not that it's a low
level it's that's what they're catching
uh there was ballots in a ditch in
pennsylvania with military vets happened
to be
overwhelmingly voting for donald trump
but they end up in a ditch
it's happening all over the place so
we're okay with mail in voting absentee
balloting like it's been done in states
where they have track records we don't
want a state that's never done it's
saying hey we're just gonna mail out
ballots i had a friend
today in new york they got two bellas
for the same person
two then i had another friend that got
one ballot in new jersey and one ballot
in new york for the same person
you know that's ridiculous the democrats
are pushing today
they don't want the signature on a
ballot to have to match the signature of
the registered voter on file
give me one good reason why you wouldn't
have those things match unless you were
trying to cheat
so we want a fair election we don't want
the gamesmanship we don't want the
cheating we have enough of a deficit
when you see what social media has been
doing certainly today but in general
censoring conservatives
when you see what mainstream media does
94 negative coverage
despite donald trump creating the
strongest america has ever economy
america has ever known
despite the lowest unemployment numbers
in the history of america
despite the highest new number of
startup businesses despite peace deals
in the middle east
and getting out of endless wars you know
donald trump is a serious record of
accomplishment i ask your viewers to
name one joe biden accomplishment
if you could be if you could do it i'd
be impressed but if you can't
and he's been there for 47 years maybe
joe biden's part of the problem
thank you guys really appreciate it